Now we will argue that
the simplex algorithm is correct,
giving us a basic feasible solution for
bounded linear programs, and
reporting that unbounded
ones are unbounded.
Let's consider the bounded case first.
First we recognize that at each
step we make some progress,
usually improving the objective value.
We have to be careful here in the case
of degenerate basic solutions.
Going back to the algorithm, remember
that we picked a new column to go into
the basis because it had a positive
corresponding value in R D,
and hence increasing it,
increased the objective value.
The trouble is that if the current
basic solution is degenerate,
that is to say that v has a zero entry,
it's possible that we won't get
to move in this direction at all.
The nightmare scenario is that
we end up in some kind of cycle.
There are two ways of
coping with this challenge.
One is to perturb
the constraints slightly.
The other is to give preference to lower
indexed columns for both entering and
leaving the basis.
This is known as blands rule.
In either case we can be assured of
making some progress in each step, but
I'll put an asterisk here because
the notion is a little tricky.
Clearly, we have a finite
number of steps,
because there are only n
choose m possible bases.
And because we make progress,
we don't cycle among them.
Now we just need to make sure
we don't stop too early.
There are two possible ways
the algorithm can terminate,
either because u is nonpositive or
rD is.
Let's consider the termination
because of u first.
This turns out to be pretty trivial.
If u is non-positive,
then we get to keep going
in the direction of dq here,
as much as we want.
Increase of the objective
value the whole way.
So clearly the problem is unbounded.
And of course that can't happen,
because we've assumed that
the linear program is bounded.
Let's consider what happens when we
terminated on the RD condition then.
We'll let x star be and optimal feasible
solution that's not necessarily basic.
And we'll let x be a basic
sub optimal solution.
While using the basis for
this basic sub optimal solution,
I can write xb star in these terms here.
This just comes from
the equality constraint.
And the feasibility of x star.
Substituting this expression
back into the objective function
gives me this result here.
This expression here is the same rD
that we obtained in the simplex method,
and because x is suboptimal, we then
have this strict inequality here.
Because x is basic and B is its basis,
however XD is 0, so
we can simply annihilate this term.
Also, XD star is non negative, so for
the strict inequality to hold, at least
one entry of rD must be positive.
Hence, if there's a better solution,
the simplex algorithm won't terminate.
That wraps up the case where
the program is bounded.
How about when it's unbounded?
Well by the same argument just given,
we won't hit the case
where rD is non-positive.
And the algorithm can't run forever,
because it avoids cycling.
And thus can only visit
each of the bases once.
The only remaining possibility is that
u will be non-positive at some point.
And we'll report that the problem
is unbounded, which, indeed, it is.